ميليسا أعلم أن درجة الحرارة تقترب بالفعل من
الصفر حيث أنت تعرف كيف
يستعد المسؤولون في المنطقة
من خلال هذا مدى سوء توقعنا
أن يكون
صباح الخير في Caitlin well vermonters
ليس غريبًا حقًا على البرد ولكن هذه
الرياح الباردة هي حقًا  كيكر هنا
الآن كما قلت ، نحن نتأرجح من
الصفر إلى درجة واحدة وقد تم بالفعل إغلاق أكثر من 200 مدرسة
هنا في فيرمونت
ويتم إغلاق العديد من منتجعات التزلج
أيضًا وهو أمر فريد من نوعه لأنهم بالطبع
يحبون البرد مثل بعض
منتجعات التزلج مثل  يظل Stow مفتوحًا مع
بعض المصاعد وبعضها ليس كذلك ولكن في الوقت الحالي
هذا شديد مع برودة الرياح التي
نشهد برودة رياح سالبة تبلغ 17 درجة
الآن ودرجات الحرارة هنا في
فيرمونت انخفضت 30 درجة منذ
منتصف الليل الآن سأعرض  أنت
شيء كنت أقوم بتجميده
بنطلون جينز طوال الصباح ، وكما ترون
هذا هو Rock Solid ، فقد استغرق الأمر
حوالي 15 دقيقة فقط للتجميد وهذا
حقًا هو درجة البرودة هنا في فيرمونت
وفي مركز Waterfront رأينا بالفعل
بعض  الناس يسبحون منذ حوالي دقيقتين فقط ، وهو أمر
مثير للاهتمام لأن
لدينا Polar Plunge هنا في
حدث سنوي تم إلغاؤه أيضًا بسبب
الطقس القاسي